Imagine you're on your last flask of healing searching for a checkpoint in the snowy wastes.
Instead, you're met with a dramatic scene:
a circular arena with an enormous glaive planted in its center.
Could it be?
You turn to leave but a mist gate blocks your way.
From behind you hear the chilling words:
[deeply] "You made a glaive mistake coming here."
And when you turn back, the enormous weapon is now in the hands of Glaive Master Hodir.
The boss bar appears, the music begins, and your life is about to end...
...Is what I might say, if I had any new Elden Ring information to share with you.
Instead, I'm just making this up.
I doubt you could even imagine that we'd be here four months ago, but there's barely been any news at all.
Oh, Elden Ring... You'd think someone would say something about it.
But instead our hopes have just been shattered with every new convention.
Gamescom: no trailers. Tokyo Game Show - nothing.
Brazil Game Show... *laughter*.
But look up the Reddit, and... you'd think it would be dead, right?
But it burns. It's on fire with posts about Elden Ring, full of users so desperate for news
that they've actually started to pretend that the game is already out.
There's a huge post ranking fictional bosses from easiest to hardest.
Folks are discussing their favorite boss music, and
don't even get them started on Glaive Master Hodir's sweep into heavy attack combo.
Glaive Master Hodir was the first boss they created, I think, and it seems like no one knows how to beat him.
But, I do. Just like you kill any meme, the way to beat this meme boss is to make him popular.
So, by bringing him to my audience, I hereby claim that I'm the first to defeat Glaive Master Hodir.
All of this fake lore and fake bosses got me thinking -
since it's unlikely we'll get Elden Ring news until the Game Awards in December
and since everyone's going hollow waiting, let's do something to pass the time.
Earlier this year, we ran the prosthetic art challenge for Sekiro - which was really fun -
and today, I'm excited to announce the first art challenge for Elden Ring.
It's going to be an effort to give form to fictional bosses, but, they have to be inspired by regional folklore
and the limited information on Elden Ring that we already have.
If you're interested in competing, tune in to the end of the video where I'm going to go over the finer details
and if you're not interested, keep listening, because
there is still a ton of Elden Ring news I haven't shared on this channel yet, coming soon.
The prize pool for this challenge is higher this time:
It's going to be two thousand US dollars and it's going to be split across the top ten participants
as shown on screen.
The reason I can fund this out of my own pocket is because you guys have been
insanely supportive of the sponsorship and merchandise stuff that I've been doing. Like, insanely supportive.
So thank you. Speaking of which, this is your last chance to buy Fate, my limited edition Elden Ring inspired merch.
I've added 48 more hours to the listing, and then this red-haired variant is gone forever.
So, check it out in the description below.
All the way back in June I penned a video about Elden Ring that was based on the trailer,
but a few days later, more information dropped, in interviews and in leaks.
Despite what I said earlier, there's a lot here you might have missed and there's even more to speculate on.
First, we have confirmation via IGN that our character will be able to traverse the world on a horse.
If mounts are required, then it really does confirm that the scale of the world is going to be huge,
because we need the mount to traverse it.
This sort of scale isn't seen in any other From Software games.
This could explain why the game seems to be eating up more development time than usual.
Incidentally, these were some of the first leaks that we received and these leaks also suggested
that we'd be traveling to distant kingdoms in order to acquire their special powers.
Hopefully the existence of different kingdoms implies that the game will be a truly open world from the very start.
I feel like so many open-world games make the mistake of designing these enormous worlds
only to put the character on rails.
Often we're restricted by the story or we're restricted by the increased difficulty in late-game areas,
but since From aren't usually restricted by story or scaling difficulty
I can imagine their open world being closer to something like Breath of the Wild's design,
with areas that you can tackle in any order and with every area having its own self-contained story.
Another common feature of open-world games are really big populated towns, but Miyazaki admits that
"Creating a more open game is a big challenge for us. If we were to add towns on top of that,
it would become a bit too much,
so we decided to create an open-world-style game focused on what we're best at."
And what they're best at is definitely not populated, heavily voice-acted towns.
So, "Villages will be the dark dungeon-like ruins that you've come to expect from us."
Usually, when games build really populated towns into them,
they often serve as a sort of reprieve from travel and combat.
They're a chance for your character to chat and trade with NPCs and also to develop the story a little bit more.
The closest parallel to something like this in From games are their hub worlds, like Firelink Shrine,
which give you a break from the endless death in the overworld.
but if Elden Ring's open world has you doing things like gathering resources or
finding traders, navigating or just looking for non-combat secrets, then, man, that's plenty of relaxation for me.
I always get kind of bored chatting to NPC's in towns so I'm not sad to see this go.
But I do wonder - what's their excuse going to be for everyone in the world being dead?
Again, maybe a sort of Ragnarok, perhaps?
So, while Miyazaki considers the gameplay to be in the same genre as Dark Souls, he also goes on to state that
"With a larger world, new systems and action mechanics inevitably become necessary.
In that sense, I think that Elden Ring is a more natural evolution of Dark Souls."
"The more extensive world will form the base of Elden Ring's gameplay
and its mechanics are designed with that type of environment in mind."
That's pretty vague. But let me try to contextualize his statements
by using other open-world games as examples.
So when he says that "new systems will become necessary as a result of the open world,"
maybe he's talking about things like preparation mechanics that make use of resources in the world,
like alchemy in The Witcher 3,
which lets you prepare for certain types of combat by giving you certain types of buffs.
He could be talking about a crafting system where you create tools and weapons from the resources around you,
like in Horizon Zero Dawn
or even weapon maintenance systems like in Metro Exodus.
He could even be talking about survival mechanics where the world itself is your enemy and is the gameplay
and you might need to take the weather or your hunger or body warmth into account.
I suppose these are examples of the world itself forming the
quote-unquote "base of Elden Ring's gameplay" as Miyazaki says.
Miyazaki goes on to say that larger environments will add more variation to battles.
So this reminds me the most of Breath of the Wild again,
where you can use the environment in creative ways to take out groups of enemies.
You can roll rocks down into their encampments,
you can steal their weapons while they sleep so that they have nothing to fight you with,
you can even do crazy things like giving them metal weapons in a storm
so that they get struck by lightning when they pick them up.
Another example might be in Horizon Zero Dawn where you can set traps ahead of difficult encounters.
I love this kind of stuff, and having more control of the world around you in Elden Ring, it could be huge.
Another fundamental difference here is that we're going to be mounted a lot of the time,
so combat must be changing to suit the increased movement speed of us and our enemies.
So, when we look at other games with mounted combat in an open world,
it usually consists of maneuvering your mount for a while,
and then there's a brief clash with a well-timed strike and then you maneuver again and clash and go on and on.
In reality a lot of this time is usually spent sprinting past your enemy, missing and getting stuck on a tree or some terrain.
For me, the best mounted combat moments usually come when some sort of slow motion or archery is involved.
But I generally end up hating the whole mounted combat experience.
But. If anyone can remove the awkwardness of mounted combat, it's From Software.
So, I fully expect them to innovate in this space
Moving away from combat, Elden Ring is said to go beyond simply bringing new twists to the formula,
like Bloodborne and Sekiro did.
Now, with a larger scale, says Miyazaki, there will be more freedom and depth to exploration.
Which I hope means there's going to be more secrets and even side quests, maybe, that aren't combat based.
Look back at Sekiro and think about all the new verticality they added to that game.
You can jump, you can grapple, swimming was incredible and...
actually, I have the feeling that these mechanics might have been a sort of beta test
for what will, surely, be in Elden Ring as well.
As for navigation in Elden Ring, my only hope is that exploration
actually requires you to engage with the world around you.
One of the worst trends in open-world games, I think, are waypoints,
and, there's always this focus on that little arrow that tells you where to go next.
And as a result you sort of stop taking in the world around you?
We've never seen what a map function looks like in a From game and
I'm keen to see their take on it, because you can design cooler ways of interacting with the world around you
to sort of figure out where you are and where you're going.
Finally, Miyazaki hopes that the world and lore can now be displayed on a grander scale.
And with genuine distance between locations now, the world should certainly feel more real.
And as for the lore, well, we'll have to talk about George RR Martin for that one.
Of the lore we currently know very little,
except that the Elden Ring once served as the rules and the rhythm of the world.
As a parallel to this, to help you understand, just think about how the Age of Fire worked in Dark Souls:
it was always rising and falling, but it was never-ending.
And whatever the Eldon ring is, it sounds like a similar "logic of the world,"
but now it's been shattered, and it seems like characters are now forced to survive in a post Elden Ring world,
a world that Miyazaki says will showcase the will of humanity.
So everything that occurred before this shattering - a.k.a. the lore - was actually written by George Martin.
He wrote about a time the player wasn't directly involved in, and then passed that story on
to the From Software team who go on to describe his writing as a sort of guide book for the world's law.
They say it's similar to having a Dungeon Master's Handbook in a tabletop RPG. Miyazaki says
"It was a fantastic collaboration, as we weren't restricted by each other,
yet we were still influenced by each other's work."
By having him write about a time that the player isn't directly involved in
he is free to unleash his creativity in the way that he likes."
"Furthermore, as FromSoftware we didn't want to create a more linear and story-driven experience for Elden Ring.
So both issues could be solved by having Martin write about the world's history instead."
"The player will be able to learn about Martin's mythology through exploration," confirmed Miyazaki,
"We're known for letting the player explore the games lore through fragments of environmental storytelling,
and this time around Martin's story is what you'll be trying to unravel."
"The period that the player actually explores is still connected to the old times,
so as you slowly discover why the world has become the way it is,
you'll learn more about Martin's mythology as well.
So, getting towards the end now,
any extra information we have at this point in the video is only really attainable from leaks.
And, when it comes to leaks in the past few months, there's only really one that's worth its salt.
Back in May there was this large post that was made on the ResetEra forums
by a renowned user called Omnipotent,
who has accurately leaked details about From Software games in the past.
If you want to read his full post, it's in the description.
But here are the safest takeaways from what they had to say. Take this with a grain of salt, of course.
According to the leaks, the game is likely to be high fantasy,
which means it's quite fantastical and not grounded in reality.
It also seems like there's going to be a very high likelihood that the game will have PvP, creative builds,
RPG elements and a sort of variable experience depending on how you build your character.
These are things that Omni says will foster good, and I quote, "YouTube content."
He even goes and spells out Scotland at one point,
which is a region with folklore that is rarely explored in game,
and this is basically going to be the basis of the art competition -
seeing how we could bring folklore from this region to life.
He also seems to make a few nods towards the same sort of vibe that Déraciné gives off,
with a world that is just out of view and yet present all the same.
Think fairies and other whimsical yet sinister beings.
It could even be inspired by William Sharp's poetry like Déraciné was.
He says that there is so much to dig into and search for,
perfect for people who like to explore and discover these worlds, lore hounds and solitary soldiers.
There's plenty of unearthed knowledge to write your paragraphs of theories about.
Uh, that's... good, and he actually puts capital letters on "Unearthed Knowledge,"
so, maybe he's suggesting that there is a sort of old world to uncover?
Or maybe underground labyrinths to explore?
Towards the end, he even mentions some themes that are common with Vikings, like runes and cello horns,
and there was even some overlap between Viking and Celtic cultures at some point in history,
so it does all seem to be coming together in that region.
Of course, like all leaks, we're going to have to wait and see
if this is validated in December before we take it all too seriously. But... I like where this is heading.
And finally, he says this journey doesn't end with E3, this is only the beginning
so don't expect to be fully satiated just yet.
But I hope this hype train will carry us there and back again, rain or shine.
"Rain or shine?" Maybe he's referring to a weather system?
Erm, but I am more concerned that he says that the hype train "might carry us all the way back to E3."
If this is true then the game might actually have a later release date than we expected.
Because, I was pretty sure they were going to show gameplay at Gamescom
and then I was pretty sure they were going to show it at Tokyo Game Show, but, now...
I'm pretty sure they're going to show gameplay at the Game Awards in December,
Hopefully I'm not wrong again. As for a release date, the earliest possible would be March 2020,
as that's when From usually releases their games and it's the end of the fiscal year in Japan.
However, their trailer releases have been later than expected.
Usually we're a bit further along at this point and there aren't many big conventions at all really that are left
to promote the game at between now and March.
Additionally, the game's scope is way bigger than recent titles,
so I honestly wouldn't be surprised if Elden Ring was the first title in a while to buck the trend
and it might actually be released later in the year.
We should all be prepared for that at least, but for now, let's move on to the art competition.
It's gonna be something that can keep us sane and entertained if we do end up having to wait a really long time.
The goal of this competition is to design and draw a boss.
And the only requirement, really, is that your inspiration must be drawn
from the folklore that Elden Ring is rumored to be inspired by.
So, that's Scandinavian/Nordic folklore, Gaelic folklore,
Irish folklore, Celtic mythology, or even Scottish mythology.
Of course, Elden Ring might not end up being inspired by these things at all,
but it's a start, and all of these places have incredible creatures and themes and stories,
and whether you choose just one of these sources or a mixture for your boss design is up to you.
In the description I've listed some reading material to sort of start you off,
but I encourage you to go beyond this and look on your own as well
Once you've chosen your inspiration and you've drawn your piece, send it to me with a bit of a written description.
Two things I'd like you to write in your email:
First, tell me what folklore that you were actually inspired by, and
Second, tell me a little bit about your boss fight.
Tell me, for example, what's its name? Where does the fight take place?
Does the fight have dialog? Does it have phases? Lore? Does the boss have weaknesses?
Does it make use of the open world in some way?
If you decide to draw a background environment, is this where the fight takes place?
Just give me some information. Don't worry about answering all these questions,
I just want you to give me some idea of what the fight is like and how it reflects your boss design.
If you're still looking for more inspiration, bear in mind that I have two videos on Elden Ring now.
There's a cinematic, where two characters in it have sort of prosthetic arms.
There's two knights in this trailer that have red hair
They're all high fantasy styled knights.
These are all sort of trends that you can maybe pull inspiration from as well,
so go watch the trailer, go watch my videos.
Hell, go on the Elden Ring subreddit and look at some of the bosses that people have just made up and posted about.
I'm sure these people would be ok with you bringing their ideas to life as long as you credit them in your email.
I've linked some really good comments from the subreddit down below.
Assuming this contest goes well, at least the top 10 winners will be featured in a video,
and there will be special mention to other contestants as well.
Prize distribution is as follows on screen and it will be delivered via PayPal.
You have until midnight on the 23rd of November, PST, to email your art to eldenringchallenge@gmail.com
Remember to include a written description of the folklore you were inspired by,
tell me how the bossfight works, list your artist portfolio, social media
and also your PayPal address, in case you win.
If you have any questions, don't email them.
Instead, head over to my Discord and go to the Elden Ring FAQ,
and see if your question has already been asked.
If it hasn't, you can ask the question in the text channel below it.
Thank you so much for your interest. I think this is gonna be fun.
If you're not an artist, maybe share this competition with an artist that you know,
and... Good luck. See you in a month.